- Hello, everyone.
Good evening.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm an astrophysicist and
on the faculty at Yale
in the Departments of
Astronomy and Physics.
I happen to serve as the current Director
of The Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
And I'm really excited to invite
you to this evening's talk.
The title of our talk
is Mozart's Starling:
A Story of Art, Language,
and the Human Relationship
with the Natural World.
Before we start, I would
first like to say thanks
to Richard and Barbara Franke
for the generous support of this program
as well as many other initiatives at Yale.
And I would also like to give a thank you
to the Connecticut Parrot Society
and the Mozart Society of America
for spreading the word about today's talk
and opening up this opportunity
for everyone to listen to
Lyanda's wonderful talk
that I'm eagerly waiting to hear.
And to introduce Lyanda and
to talk about birding in general,
we have our local international
expert evolutionary ornithologist,
Professor Rick Prum,
who incidentally was the inaugural
and previous director
of the Franke Program.
Rick, as many of you know, Rick Prum,
for those of you who might
have read his wonderful books,
has done research on
diverse topics including
avian final genetics, behavior evolution,
evolution of aesthetics.
And most of all, he is an avid birder.
So I would like to turn over
hosting today's event to Rick.
And Rick, welcome and thank you so much.
- Thank you, Priya,
and a pleasure to be here today
visiting with the Franke
Program in our new
or our accustomed Zoom state.
First, thanks again to
Rich and Barbara Franke
and great to see them here today.
It's my pleasure to
introduce the speaker today.
Lyanda Haupt is an award
award-winning author,
naturalist, and eco philosopher
whose writing in multiple books
has connected nature and biodiversity
to the everyday lives of people.
Her previous books include
The Urban Bestiary:
the Encountering of
Everyday Life in the Wild,
Crow Planet: Essential Wisdom
for the Urban Wilderness,
and Pilgrim on the Great Bird Continent:
Importance of Everything and Other Lessons
from Darwin's Notebooks.
All published by Little Brown.
In the next month, she
has a new book coming out,
Rooted: Life at the Crossroads
of Science, Nature and Spirit
with Little Brown.
And today we have the
pleasure from hearing from her
on her award-winning book
in 2017, Mozart's Starling.
So thank you and welcome to
the Franke Program, Lyanda.
- Thank you so much.
I'm delighted to be here.
I want to begin with some gratitude.
Thank you to the Frankes
for your generosity.
I am so happy to be part
of this beautiful series.
Thank you, Professor Natarajan.
I'm sure I said your name incorrectly but.
And thank you, Professor Prum,
for that lovely introduction.
And thank you to Professor
Ty Kamp for arranging this.
We had so many emails back and forth
figuring out how things would go.
And who else should I thank?
I know who.
Frederick.
Professor Kamp's son, Frederick,
I hear started this whole adventure
with a thoughtful holiday gift.
So well done, Frederick.
Thank you.
So--
- Lyanda, I forgot to thank Carmen
for today's talk as well to be featured.
So I wanted to say thank you
to both you, our wonderful speaker,
and our participant, active
participant hopefully,
Carmen, who will be there.
And I also wanted to
give a shout out because
to Rick's book, which is,
this is one of my absolute
favorite books as well.
So I think for all of
you, without further ado,
Lyanda, please take it away.
- One further delay, if I may, I'm sorry.
I was remiss, I should have mentioned.
Please put your questions
during the talk in the chat
and we'll monitor the chat.
And at the end of the day,
we'll get to as many of
those questions as we can.
So thank you.
And now.
- Onward.
Okay, yes, ask me anything.
All right, I'm gonna
pop the share screen on.
I wish that we were in
person together, of course.
It's wonderful to be so.
But one of the things that this platform
gives us the opportunity
to do is to gather
from places all over the place.
And so I wanted to share briefly that I am
speaking to you from Seattle
in the Pacific Northwest.
We are surrounded by the Cascade Mountains
and the Olympic Mountains.
And this is really a land of
mountains and rivers without end.
Lots of ferns and mosses.
And just down the road from my house
is a wooded forested
path to the Salish Sea.
And so I want to say at this point
that I live and work on the unceded lands
of the Duwamish Tribe and
the Coast Salish peoples.
And I acknowledge with
honor and so much gratitude
this land and the people
who have lived here
from time immemorial.
If you can see, I'm
gonna kind of pop this up
'cause we've got a bird coming through.
I'm kind of laughing because the title
of this lecture series is the
Distinguished Speaker Series.
And yet I am coming to you from my kitchen
with a starling on my
head and pandemic hair.
And I'm feeling that the
whole kitchen situation
is very undistinguished.
And I promise you that
upstairs in my study,
there's lots of books,
high distinguished level.
But the reason that we're here is that
Ty Kamp and I were
talking before this series
about whether or not Carmen could join
for the Q&A afterwards.
And I said, she's welcome to join the talk
and that would be fun but
she has a mind of her own
and there's no guaranteeing
that if we just open the door
of her aviary for the Q&A
that she'll come out then.
So I decided, we decided together,
to just have the door of her aviary open.
It's really close by here.
This is her most comfortable room.
So she might be flying in and out.
And I think we might just be a
little bit light on our feet.
And I might talk about
starling natural history
not necessarily in the
order that I had planned it
just so that we can take
advantage of having the bird here.
So I usually start by doing a little poll.
And I'm not gonna do the Zoom poll.
I just would like you all to humor me
and from wherever you are,
if you are a person who
feels that you could,
with maybe 95% accuracy,
identify a starling when you see one,
please raise your hand.
Okay.
Lots.
Lots of hands and not all the
hands, just as to be expected.
So I will tell you that if
you did raise your hand,
you are really in the upper
just few percent strata
of people in this country.
Most people do not know,
if they know anything about birds at all,
what they know about starlings is that
we are supposed to dislike them.
But very few people can identify them.
Many people think that
they are crows, baby crows,
conflating smallness with baby-ness
as people often do, or
blackbirds generally.
I was speaking with a
very illustrious person
in the opera world when I
was researching this book.
And we were sitting at
a coffee shop in Seattle
where he has lived for two decades.
And he knew about that
Mozart had a starling
and we were talking a lot about that.
And he finally came to a
point in the conversation
where he leaned over and he said,
but you know, I've never seen a starling.
And I thought, oh my goodness.
So I said,
Maestro, just lean over this way into the,
to the,
and look at the wire above the coffee shop
and there are four
starlings sitting there.
And he just laughed.
I said, you're walking under them
every single day of your life.
A question that I'm often
asked is why I wrote this book.
And it's a question
that every author gets.
It's more fitting for me with this book
because I am an
ecologically minded person.
I'm a nature writer.
I'm a student of bird life.
And if there's one thing that
people know about starlings
is that they are the most
despised bird in North America,
for people that know anything
about conservation and ornithology,
and that's with good reason.
They cause $800 million of
agricultural damage every year.
They are a non-native species
and an invasive species.
So they have grown in from
when they were introduced here in 1890
from a population of just 80 birds
to the 200 million starlings
that now blanket North America.
And their main ecological
issue is that they compete with
native cavity nesters,
for that rare resource of cavity nests.
So small birds like chickadees,
certain woodpeckers,
blue birds and things like that.
So.
People say why would I of all people
write a book about starlings?
And it's something that I
never thought I would do.
I had already,
I apologize that the
starling is fluttering
through my already bad pandemic hair, so.
It's kind of a
funny situation.
It's okay, Carmen.
So one day I was working
on a completely different book at my desk
and I looked out the
window at the parking strip
and what I saw was about, it was autumn,
and so the family groups of summer
were starting to break down
and gather into the larger flocks
that characterize the huge
gatherings of starlings
in autumn and into the winter.
And I was looking out there and I thought,
dang it, there's 30 starlings.
They're scaring away the
cute little chickadees
that I would rather have out there.
So I pounded on the window and the birds,
I had a teenager at the time,
so I recognized the
look that they gave me.
It was just, it was complete indifference.
They kind of looked up at me like,
yeah, we don't care what you think.
And so I pounded harder.
And this time, the starlings
lifted from the grass
and they turned into the light,
and then of course they
didn't actually leave.
They went back onto the sidewalk.
But in that moment,
the light captured that
beautiful iridescence
of their feathers.
And I thought, you know,
I might dislike starlings,
but dang, they are so, so pretty.
And then I noticed it
seemed kind of serendipitous
that, at the same time,
Spotify was on and Mozart's
Prague Symphony was playing.
And I didn't know at the
time that that was a symphony
that he composed during the time
that he lived with a starling.
But I did sort of have that
sense of things coming together.
And I remembered in that moment
the story that I'd heard
over and over again
and even had written about
just briefly in earlier books,
that Mozart had a pet starling.
And I sat there contemplating
that kind of dissonance.
That here in,
here is this composer
that we consider to be
one of the most sublime voices
in the Western classical canon.
And he had, as a muse and a companion,
this most despised of birds.
And I should point out that
in Europe, where Mozart is from,
starlings are native birds
and so they don't have the
reputation that they have here.
So I sat there kind of dwelling
in that complicated dissonance
and I just went down the rabbit hole
of exploring the story.
And the thing that I
had to start with was,
was it even true?
Because there are so many
apocryphal stories about composers.
There's an idea that Beethoven
cut the legs off of his piano
because he was deaf and he
could sit on the floor and hear
the tremblings of movement or vibrations
of the piano while he played.
And that is very, very
likely an untrue story.
And I thought, gosh,
maybe I've been misled
by this Mozart starling story.
But it turns out that it is true.
Did a little research and found out
that this is pretty much the way it went.
In April of 1784,
Mozart was living in Vienna and
he just finished a new concerto.
It was the beautiful Concerto in G Major.
And he was not very
good at keeping records
but one thing that he did
keep really good track of
was his finished music.
So he wrote in his composition diary
that he had completed this concerto.
It was K.453.
The 453rd finished piece that
he had written at age 24.
Makes me feel kind of lazy.
And there were hundreds
of others of smaller,
lesser compositions that he didn't think
worthy of making it into the diary.
So anyway, April 1784.
Wrote the concerto.
He had a fair copy of it made
to send to his father, Leopold,
the great violinist and violin pedagogue
who was living in Salzburg
about 250 miles away,
by kind of rough carriage road.
So he had that sent to his
father along with a letter
that said, Father, I would
love your opinion about this.
He always valued Leopold's good opinion.
But he said, please be
very careful with it.
Don't let anyone see it.
Mozart was always a little bit paranoid
that his work was going to be stolen
or copied or imitated
by a lesser composer.
And not without reason.
This happened sometimes.
So this is all in April.
Sent it to his father, and in
May, he got confirmation that
Leopold in Salzburg had received it.
This composition was slated
to be performed in June in Vienna.
So April, it's finished.
June, it's going to be performed.
In the middle in May, May 26th of 1784,
Mozart went into a bird shop,
and he lived in the Graben area of
that kind of fashionable
shopping district of Vienna,
then and now.
And so he went downstairs
from his apartments
and he was walking the street.
He walked into a bird vendor's shop
and he bought a starling
for three kreutzer.
And the starling was singing
the motif from the concerto,
from Allegretto movement,
of the Concerto in G.
So we know this because,
although I said that Mozart
is a terrible record keeper,
he did for a while keep
a small expense notebook
where he wrote down everything
that he ever bought.
And it's kind of funny.
It's anomalous 'cause it wasn't something
that he would normally do.
He was married to Constanze Weber Mozart,
who was very good at home economics.
She had to be because their economic
finances were in such disarray.
So in my imagination,
it was her, Constanze,
that gave the notebook
to Mozart with the admonition,
honey, I want you to write
down every single thing
that you buy every day
and then show it to me
at the end of the week and we'll talk.
So Mozart was really good about that.
And he wrote down three
kreutzer for the bird
and right underneath it, he wrote down
what he heard.
So this is Mozart a couple
of years before this.
This is Mozart at about 22 years old.
He was 24 when he got the bird.
And this is what he heard.
So what this slide does,
if you're not musical, don't worry.
But it shows the line of the motif
that the starling was singing
and it shows it the way
that Mozart wrote it
and then the way the starling sang it.
So the starling made a couple of changes.
If you're not musical, don't worry.
But there's this little
arch with the dot under it.
That's a fermata, a long pause.
And then you'll also see that
the bird sharped the G's.
Which sounds absolutely terrible,
but it's exactly the sort of
thing that a starling would do.
So I'm gonna play this for you.
And this is just me plunking it on
the piano in the living room.
And if you listen carefully,
you'll be able to hear Carmen
from way over here in the,
kind of the mudroom where her aviary is,
singing in the background.
So listen for the changes.
Listen carefully to the first line.
The starling does not
sing the grace notes.
But here we go.
(soft piano music)
(bird singing)
I hope you could hear Carmen
in the background there.
So a lot of, most people,
most biographers of Mozart
do not mention the starling at all
because it takes some sleuthing
to get to the bottom of the story.
You have to look at diaries, notebooks,
letters from visitors
and from Mozart himself,
and other ephemera.
But when people do mention the starling,
and there's a lot of misinformation about
what the starling could sing
and what the starling couldn't sing,
when they come to the idea that Mozart
heard the starling mimicking his motif,
that he must've been furious.
So starlings are gifted mimics.
So it wasn't really strange
that a starling could do this.
And I will talk about that,
more about that in a little bit.
People thought he must've been furious
because he really was paranoid that
people were going to copy
and imitate his music.
And here somehow, it
had gotten in the world
enough that a bird, the
starling, a good mimic,
could learn to mimic it.
But the information that
we have from Mozart himself
in the little notebook that he kept
was the record that he bought the bird,
these two lines that
he copied, and we have,
Mozart had absolutely perfect pitch.
So we know that his version
of the starling song was exactly right.
And then underneath that,
instead of some exclamation of fury,
he wrote, and I, forgive
me, I do not speak German,
but the line is (speaking
in foreign language).
That was wonderful.
So.
So we have the real Carmen here
and you guys will have to tell
me since I can't see myself,
if I'm situated well
enough that you guys can,
y'all can see her.
Is this all right?
- [Ty] Yep, you're fine.
- Okay good, so as you can see,
Carmen looks a little bit different
than the young bird she
was in that photograph.
One of the questions that
people often ask is how.
They think that I talk
about this wonderful mystery
of Mozart coming to have the starling,
and it's a multilayered mystery.
And one of the questions
that people ask me most is,
how did a starling learn
to sing this motif?
And how is really not
that much of a mystery.
Starlings are gifted mimics.
And in this country especially,
in North America where
starlings are so despised,
people bother to learn
very little about them.
But they are better mimics
than the corvids, the
crows and jays and ravens.
And they are on par with some parrots.
So it depends on the starling
and it depends on the parrot.
(laughs) But they're very capable mimics
and they mimic environmental
sounds, other birds,
animals, music, and the human
voice and many other things.
So the real issue is when
the starling learned Mozart's concerto,
because as I said, he
finished it in April.
It wasn't supposed to be out until June.
So we don't know if
Mozart visited the shop
and taught the bird
the motif himself when
he was whistling along,
as he often did,
or whether he heard Mozart
practicing out the window
from his apartments above,
or there are all kinds
of other possibilities
of the way that the starling
could have learned it.
And in most, whenever,
you'll read about this in program notes
when you go to the symphony
and hear this concerto performed.
And I am absolutely shocked at how often
the course of events described
are absolutely impossible.
Or people will say,
learned people will say in program notes
that the starling could
sing the whole concerto,
which even for a starling is too much.
Or that the starling sang
a couple of notes flat,
which no respectable
starling would sing flat.
(laughs) So one of the
things that I enjoyed doing
was all the research that it really came
to narrow down the possibilities
of what could have actually happened.
So I really went down the rabbit hole
of exploring the relationship
with Mozart and his starling.
I read every scientific
paper that I could find
in any language that I could
read, which is English.
So. (laughs)
I've read all of the
scientific literature.
I put my binoculars around my neck
and went out into the
urban wilds and studied
starlings extensively in the field.
I traveled to Vienna and spent days
in the apartments where
Mozart lived with his starling
to kind of imagine how their life
would have gone together there.
And I realized that there was one thing
that was missing in all of this research
that I really needed to do
in order to understand how
Mozart lived with a starling.
And that was to take a drastic step.
And live with a starling myself. (laughs)
So let me first say
that it is absolutely illegal to
harm, touch, even glance
sideways at any nest, nestlings,
or most birds in North America.
So it is completely illegal to have
a nestling bird of most kinds.
Most birds are protected by
the Migratory Bird Treaty Act.
Starlings are an exception.
In being a non-native
bird and an invasive bird,
they are not protected by the Treaty Act
or Fish and Wildlife.
And we are not only allowed
but actually encouraged
by federal and local Fish
and Wildlife departments
to remove starling nests
and eggs and even nestlings
in any way that we can.
So I personally agree
that we should find ways
to limit starling nests and eggs.
But I personally ethically believe
that after the nestlings are hatched
is not the time to remove the nestlings.
I did, however, learn
when I was on the hunt
for a starling for my research
that there was a nest in Seattle Park,
not far from my home,
that was gonna be removed
by the Fish and Wildlife
or the City Parks Department.
And I had an insider in the parks who knew
the research that I was working
on and he told me about it.
And I said, those starlings
have actually hatched already,
because I've been studying
all the starlings in the area.
And he said, well, no one cares.
They're just starlings.
So he said, it's gonna happen tonight.
(laughs) You haven't had that much time.
So as with a lot of
so-called wildlife control,
when animals are removed by wildlife
or killed by wildlife,
Fish and Wildlife organizations
or City Parks Department,
they do it at night so that
people don't get upset.
So I told my husband
that it was our one
chance to get a starling
and he was a little bit dubious about it
but we went up to the park.
It was a harrowing
adventure that involved us
sneaking into the boys'
bathroom at a park,
borrowing the park's garbage can,
climbing on top of it.
Starlings are cavity nesters
and they like to nest far enough back
that a raccoon's paw cannot reach them.
And in this case, the
starlings were way, way back
in the eaves of this kind of
slightly open aired bathroom.
So I climbed up there and I couldn't reach
and my husband climbed up
there with his long arm
and he could just, we could feel the heat
of the starling nestlings but
we couldn't quite reach them.
And finally, with me sort of leaning
on this garbage can against the wall
to keep it from falling out
from under my poor husband
so he wouldn't end up
just dangling by his arm
from the boys' bathroom ceiling,
finally, he grasped the starling chick
and he dropped it in my hands.
And the chick was only a few days old.
And I looked at this
little bird and I thought,
oh my goodness, this bird is so sickly.
She was wheezing.
She had ectoparasites that I could
literally see crawling all over her.
And she just didn't seem,
she seemed highly ephemeral.
And I said, honey, it would
be better if we had two.
They could keep each other warm.
And the glare I got from
my husband in that moment
with him standing there with
his bruised arm was just,
it was priceless but it also told me
that we were going to have
just the one starling.
Carmen.
So.
What I didn't realize is that
I have a background in
rehabilitation of birds,
especially raptors, but at
the Raptor Center in Vermont,
people would bring in all kinds of birds.
And so I'd raised starlings before
and many other young birds but
I didn't realize that raising one
just from a few days to adulthood
would take over my life.
And this is a video, and
we were testing it before
and we found out that it's just not,
it's not playing very well.
It's a little bit glitchy.
But this is how she looked from
my writing desk.
So I would sit every day,
writing this book, Mozart's Starling.
My laptop is in the middle of my desk.
To the right was this little
tiny Tupperware with this
kind of frightful, getting
uglier by the day, baby starling
and hungrier as well,
who needed feeding every
20 minutes from dawn to dusk.
And on the other side of my computer,
there was often Delilah the cat.
And it was really funny.
Delilah knew that she wasn't
supposed to eat the bird.
But she would ever so slightly
reach over with her paw.
And I'd say, Delilah, nope.
And she'd pull it back and just pretend
to be licking herself.
And I'm just gonna put
this on just for a second
and see if you can get a sense of it.
And I'm not gonna leave
it on for the whole time
'cause I know it's not really gonna work,
but I'm just gonna keep my fingers crossed
and see if you can get
a little bit of a vibe.
Here, baby.
Just from my end.
(bird chirping)
So I'm sorry if that
didn't look good for you,
but it's just kind of a fun little image
of the cheeping bird that
was my constant company.
What was really funny about this
and what I didn't expect was how limiting
this would be to my movement.
I had to be,
I did have to feed her every 20 minutes
and keep her a certain temperature.
I basically couldn't leave the house.
If I went for a walk and I was back,
it took me 22 minutes instead of 20,
I would walk inside and I
would hear this incredible
churring sound.
There's this very loud churring sound
that young starlings make.
They outgrow it in a couple of months.
But it would just be pouring
over the whole house.
And I would rush up to feed her.
And one time I thought,
I'm tired of being stranded
and I need groceries.
And so I packed her up in her box,
I packed her up with the food,
and I just went to the
nearest grocery store.
And by the time I got there,
she was so cold 'cause she
needs to be about 85 degrees.
I had a lamp for her at home.
And so what I had to do
is I literally took her
and put her in my bra,
(laughs) ran in, got my milk and bread,
came out again and thought,
all right, I'm never doing this again.
And you can see this
little stirring stick here
in the slide.
One of the things that's interesting
about keeping a baby starling is that
although we are allowed to do anything
that we want to starlings,
kill and maim them,
we are not legally
allowed to take them home
and raise them in our living rooms.
They don't want people
having pet starlings
that they might propagate.
So I was already a minor felon
in terms of taking the bird,
but then I ran into Starbucks
and stole a whole handful of
those little stirring sticks
to feed her with.
So my rap sheet was just getting
really long at this point.
And even though she was
so sickly and wheezing,
with a lot of care, Carmen grew very fat.
She did get uglier before she got cuter.
We couldn't tell for certain whether
she was a male or female at this point.
So we chose the name Carmen,
which could be used for males or females.
I love this juvenile plumage.
They have this very white chin
that allows them to be found from below,
which we discovered when
Carmen flew out the kitchen
window one day and she got lost
and we found her high, high
in a fir tree outside our home.
Partly by a contact call
that she was making,
but partly by the whiteness of her chin.
So this is a little kind
of family photo album.
Quickly, Carmen became
so at home among us.
And I don't know if she thinks that
we are starlings or that she is
and we're part of her flock
or she's part of our human family.
Either way, she is very much at home.
And so this is kind of a little album
of how things look at home.
This is a look at a
plumage that we rarely see
because the birds only keep
it for a couple of weeks,
and it's a time when they are cared for
and still pretty hidden by their parents.
So I like throwing this
in for bird people.
Claire, my daughter, is reading Jane Eyre
and Carmen loved to sit on her shoulder
and kind of snuggle under her
hair while she was reading.
And here she is all
grown into her beautiful
teenage juvenile plumage.
So this is what it looked like
and what it often looks like for me
to be researching or
writing on any given day.
Carmen does like to be up with me.
And the reason that I didn't take her up
into my study today is
that sometimes she decides
all of a sudden that
she's anxious up there
and wants to leave.
And I didn't want to interrupt our talk.
But as you can see,
I'm just noticing in this photo,
there's a lot of books
reflected in the window.
So you can see that it actually
is very distinguished up there. (laughs)
Anyway, Carmen would sit on my shoulder
and she makes every single task I do
take twice as long as it normally would.
She steals my post-its.
She gets into all kinds of trouble.
She sits on my hands
while I'm trying to type
and just creates all kind of a ruckus
but does like to be with me
no matter what I'm doing.
She sends messages that
I'm not ready to send.
She likes Facebook posts
that I do not like.
It's been a little bit of a problem.
But all of that I think looks
really kind of tranquil,
like it's fun having a
starling around, and it is,
but what it doesn't show is the background
symphony of starling sound
that we live with in our home.
So I hope that this works.
I want to talk a little bit
about what you're gonna hear.
So in this video,
Carmen has two different
kinds of vocalizations.
One is the array of starling,
just typical starling vocalizations.
And for people who are interested
in birds and ornithology,
starlings are a songbird
and it is typical for most species that
the male of the species is
the singer and sings the,
I mean, males and females
both have many vocalizations,
but it's the male that
typically sings the species,
what is recognized as the species song
in the breeding season for many reasons.
In part to attract a mate,
to create and defend a
territory and other things.
For a few birds, and
starlings are among them,
females also sing.
So male and female
starlings sing year round.
They don't just use their
chatty vocalizations.
They use actual song year round.
It becomes more frequent and more animated
for male birds during the breeding season.
And it is also during the breeding season
that female starlings fall
absolutely silent on their nest.
The first time this happened with Carmen,
I thought that she was
depressed or that there was,
I was doing something wrong.
But I've learned that
she does it seasonally.
And so it is little wonder
that it was only recently,
I mean, it was a little
bit over 10 years ago,
that we finally figured out
that female starlings also sing.
So in this little clip,
you'll hear starling vocalizations,
but mixed in, you'll
hear some of that mimicry
that characterizes the talents,
the mimicry talents of the starling.
What's in here?
So you're gonna hear,
'cause it's a little,
it's all a little bit whistly,
but you'll hear the whir
of the coffee grinder.
You'll hear the creak of our oak floor.
Once Carmen learns new
sounds all of the time,
even though she is almost seven years old,
starlings, again, this is
different for starlings
from other songbirds.
Most songbirds usually use
learn their species song
and other vocalizations within
the first year or so of their life.
And then that's it.
But starlings, like some other mimics,
are lifelong learners.
So they will actually mimic novel sounds
and continue learning
throughout their lives.
And Carmen's working on a new sound now.
I'm trying to figure out what it is.
And this happens a lot.
If she's not imitating or mimicking
a human vocalization or a piece of music,
it'll be some environmental sound
and I cannot figure it out.
And so one of those was this sound
where she goes (sings).
And I thought, what is going on?
And finally I stepped outside
just over the threshold of
where she usually hangs out,
and I stepped on our old wood oak floor
and it creaked in just
that same way. (sings)
And I thought, she's
just mimicking the place
that I step every day.
Also in here in quick succession,
you'll hear a meow, a hi
honey, and a kissy sound
like that (puckers lips)
that you use to call animals,
and also a come here, honey.
So I'll play it, I hope that
you'll be able to hear it,
and I'll kind of point out
the sounds as they come.
(bird whistling)
That was coffee grinder.
- What?
- Well, you're not
doing all the school for.
- [Girl] What? It's just a bird.
(bird whistling)
- Carmen is responding to that.
So I hope people could hear that okay.
So.
Carmen uses her mimicry
in three different ways
that I have noticed.
One of them is that she just
mixes it in like she did here.
So she's making a lot of
typical starling noises
and she throws some of her
favorite mimic sounds inside.
She also does it randomly.
So I will be sitting in the
living room by myself, say,
and she'll be in her aviary.
She goes into her aviary for the evening.
We like to leave it open
so she can get as much
freedom of flight as possible.
But in the evening she starts
sort of bunking around.
So we make sure she's safe
inside when dusk falls.
But I will be in the living room
and I'll hear her say
just from the next room,
come here, honey.
And I'll sit there going,
am I supposed to go there?
(laughs) This is sort of,
it's a little bit haunting
and kind of super interesting.
But the other way is participatory.
And I'm sorry I don't
have the slide for you.
It was a, I don't know what happened but
I'll at least tell you the story.
So every morning when I come downstairs,
I'm usually the first one awake,
I'll come downstairs and
Carmen will look at me
and the first thing that she'll say,
in this hushed whispered
voice is, hi Carmen.
Because that's what she usually hears
when I come down the stairs first thing.
And then our big cat Delilah
will come down the stairs
and Carmen will look at Delilah,
and before Delilah says
anything, Carmen says, (meows).
And then when I go and I pick up
the jar of coffee beans to make the coffee
but before I start the coffee
grinder, she says, (whirs).
And then, and this is the
video I hope to show you,
when I open and close
the door of the microwave
but before I press the buttons,
she'll say, beep beep beep.
And it is pitch perfect.
We literally cannot tell them apart.
We cannot tell the microwave from Carmen.
And so it took me months
of living with a starling
who had this wonderful aural attunement
to recognize something
that is little understood
and little studied or
discussed in the literature.
And that is that Carmen,
starling vocalizations,
now I have no idea what's
going on with my hair
after all that starling
visitation. (laughs)
Starlings' aural involvement
with their environment
is not only participatory,
but it is anticipatory.
So she is always in the world, waiting,
aurally attuned to what is going on
and ready to participate by proclaiming
the sound that is about to happen.
And this is, I just think,
the most magnificent knowledge
and it took me so long to figure it out.
And then to realize, my first thought was,
wow, I have a really smart
starling in my house.
But of course, it's
not just this starling.
It is a capacity of all starlings
to live with this wild aural attunement.
And so when I step through the door,
it makes me realize,
just from learning from this little bird,
makes me realize that we live within this
infinity of consciousness.
Okay, I'm not even, consciousnesses.
There we go.
An infinity of intelligences
that is beyond our knowing
and even our imagining.
And it makes the world
seem so full of wonder.
I think of Emerson's quote,
we lie in the lap of an
immense intelligence.
And so,
I just think it's one of
the most wonderful things
I've learned from living with a starling.
And when I think about it,
I know that we have ecological
issues with the starling
but I think this,
what we are learning from their
song and their vocalizations
is so magnificent.
What could be wrong?
(humming)
I don't know if you can
see, I can't see myself.
Enter Noam Chomsky.
Shout out to Steve Harrington
who has a company in Portland
called Just Say Gnome.
He read my book and he
learned that I borrowed
the statue of garden Noam
Chomsky from a friend,
and he sent me my own.
So very happy.
So back in the 1950s,
this very bright young
linguist, Noam Chomsky,
was hanging out at MIT,
thinking a lot about what
makes human language unique.
And you have to remember that in the '50s,
behaviorism was very popular
and BF Skinner had the prominent
theory about how children learn language.
And he felt that it was through rewards.
So if a kid says something right,
the mom give him a pat on the head
or a cupcake or something,
and they get all of this
positive reinforcement.
And Noam Chomsky thought, and rightly,
that that was nonsense.
He came up over years
with a very different idea
that we have a rule-based,
innate rule-based way of
coming to apprehend and utilize language.
He called it universal grammar.
And one of the most important aspects
of this universal grammar or rules
was a certain kind of syntax.
So as humans, there's two different ways
that we add information and
complexity to our sentences.
One of them is by just
adding onto it,
adding onto the end of the sentence.
So say we have a sentence
like, Mozart played the violin.
We could add to it by saying,
Mozart played the violin
and had a pet bird.
and had a pet bird
who liked to sit on his shoulder.
And we could keep doing that forever.
And for some weird reason,
the metaphor that I used in the book
was a rat growing a longer tail.
And for some other weird
reason, I didn't edit it out.
I still use that metaphor.
So the rat's tail is
growing longer and longer,
adding onto it brick by
brick, check by check.
But the other way that humans
complexify our sentences
is from the inside out,
through a syntactical
device called recursion.
So when we say, instead of saying,
Mozart played the violin
and had a pet starling,
we could say, Mozart,
who played the violin,
had a pet starling.
Mozart, who played the
violin and enjoyed singing,
had a pet starling.
And we could grow that
sentence from within
over and over again forever.
So instead of being like
the rat with a tail,
it's our sentences become like peonies.
These layered, blossoming from within.
And we see recursion
sometimes in music as well,
including the music of Mozart.
But this became very
important for Noam Chomsky,
who decided that it was
a cornerstone of his universal grammar
that all humans and only humans
recognize recursivity
in the way that we use our language.
So anthropologists are actually busy
debunking the first part of that,
that all humans recognize recursion.
But the really interesting
thing is that starlings
are the first animal to prove
the second part of
Chomsky's theory incorrect.
So there is a neuropsychologist,
Tim Gentner, at UC San Diego.
And he did some studies where he took
starling sounding voices,
little bits of them,
and he made them into patterns.
He made them into linear
patterns like AABB
and then he made them
into recursive patterns
where he'd stick a different pattern
in the middle of this linear pattern.
And what he found was that
although it took some doing,
it took many of the starlings
thousands of tries listening,
that they could ultimately
recognize recursive patterns.
So.
When Noam Chomsky heard this
research, he was furious.
He woke from his dogmatic slumbers
and he rushed to critique the study.
And he denounced the starling's behavior
as being nothing more than
memorizing or counting rattles.
He said there was basically party tricks.
And actually the things
that he was suggesting
the starlings were doing were
very complex behaviors for
a bird like a starling.
But he was unwilling to entertain the idea
that they were recognizing recursion.
And so later, Tim Gentner took great pains
to make his studies more complexified
and make the patterns more difficult
so that there was really no way to claim
that the starlings were
just acting from memory
or counting.
So.
Yeah, you really have to side
with the starling science on that,
which is quite fascinating.
So linguistics were one of the ways,
one of the main ways that
I ended up, to my surprise,
I didn't expect to go down
the path of linguistics.
By the way, I found myself on
the screen here, so thank you.
It's the way that we're arranged.
Did not expect to go down
the path of linguistics.
And we can talk more about
that if you want to in the Q&A.
There's just so much fun stuff there
about the anthropological
dimension as well.
I did expect to go into music.
And one of the things
that surprised me was
I've discovered the work of a
very well-known neurophysicist
and she said the most remarkable thing.
She said, I want to get the quote right.
That only humans have the
capacity to engage with music.
Only humans have the capacity
to engage with music.
And I read that aloud at
our dinner table one night
and everyone just cracked up
because we live with this
starling who is, who cannot,
we cannot have music going on in the house
without her reacting wildly.
And I had this great fantasy
when Carmen came to the house.
I didn't want to teach her
any particular vocalization.
I just wanted to see how her
mimicry and vocal learning would unfold
in the general household
round of our daily life.
But I did have one
exception and that is that,
I'm so sorry, I was just
making sure she's not
bathing in the cat water
which is bad for her.
She's bathing in some other water
that she's not allowed to be in,
but it's safe at least.
So the exception was that I was hoping
she would learn to sing or mimic
the line that Mozart's starling sang,
that from his Allegretto
from the Concerto in G Major.
So I put it on loop on my phone
and I played it for
her over and over again
while she was growing up and
she had no interest whatsoever.
And here I'm thinking it would be
the perfect conclusion to the book
and she'd be famous and Oprah would come.
But she just doesn't give it a glance.
But other music, she leaps to life
like an opera hero when she hears it.
And she doesn't like
much of Mozart at all.
She does like the theme of Papageno,
this very birdlike character
from The Magic Flute
that I believe to be inspired in some part
by Mozart's time with this starling.
She also likes one of his Divertimento,
A Musical Joke,
that he wrote during the
time that she lived with
or that his starling
lived with him as well.
And the famous ornithologist, Baptista,
and an ethologist, Meredith West,
sort of over-played the Musical Joke
overlain with the starling vocalizations,
and definitely found the
vocal imprint of the starling
on this piece of Mozart's
that has for so long
been despised by musicians everywhere
because it makes them sound so discordant
and like they don't
know what they're doing.
But it seems like Mozart knew
exactly what he was doing.
He was composing a kind of
musical eulogy for his bird.
Anyway, other than those
couple of exceptions,
Carmen unfortunately has
little interest in Mozart.
But she loves Bach and
she loves bluegrass.
And she was fortunate with Bach
because Claire, my
daughter, is a fine cellist.
And so we had the
unaccompanied cello squeaks
going on in the house a lot
and Carmen would sing along with them.
And my husband happens
to be a bluegrass fan
and this is how we discovered
Carmen's love of bluegrass.
And she even has a favorite
band, Greensky Bluegrass,
and I think it's because they have
a really strong mandolin line
and the mandolin lies within her vocal,
her natural sort of vocal range.
So I tried this out before
we all gathered here with the panelists
and it seemed a little
bit loud and distorted,
but I'm gonna give it a try
'cause I will tell you that
it also sounds kind of loud
and distorted from our home.
We'll have bluegrass playing
and then Carmen will be singing along.
So if you want to ask,
what I mean when I disbelieve the sense
that only humans can
be engaged with music,
I will show you that,
what it looks like when
Carmen is engaged with music.
(upbeat music)
(bird singing)
So I hope that worked.
Where's my...
Don't worry, I won't make
you listen to that anymore.
I hope you could get a sense of that.
So, oh wow, I do really have
starling hair. (laughs)
All right.
What I love when I listen to
Carmen engaging with music
is thinking about her interaction or
Mozart's bird's interaction
with his family.
And I actually believe
his starling to be male.
So even though I said
that males and females
are both really gifted mimics,
just really sing the,
males have a little
bit of an edge on that.
It seems that females might be able to
apprehend complexity in
sound and vocalizations
better than male starlings can.
But males can mimic a little
bit better than females.
And so because Mozart's
bird was such a gifted mimic
and could mimic part of this concerto,
I believe him to be a male.
And plus it was easier for me to write
to have a male starling
and a female starling.
So I love thinking of Mozart
with his starling in his home.
This is before he was married.
Mozart with his sister, Nannerl,
that's his mother, Anna Maria,
in the back who has passed,
and his father, Leopold.
And this is getting long so I'm going to
just say a couple more things.
Anna Maria died
when Mozart was 21 in Paris.
And Leopold died
while Mozart had his starling
and he lived in Vienna while
Leopold was living in Salzburg.
Leopold died in 1787.
He was 62 years old
which was a pretty good age for the time.
And at the time, Mozart
didn't attend the funeral.
And much was made of this,
and still is by biographers,
that it shows that Leopold
was very kind of authoritarian
and controlling and officious
with Mozart, which he was,
but there's also, when
you read their letters,
just so much love between them.
At the time that Leopold died,
Mozart had young children in the house.
Constanze was sick with a septic leg
and their financial
situation was terrible.
And by the standards of the day,
a funeral was very expensive.
So if Mozart went and
created a memorial service
for his father in Salzburg,
remember 250 miles away,
he would've had to lay out for
the expenses of the funeral
and even hire mourners,
which is something they did at the time.
So it wasn't that Mozart didn't go
or didn't want to go to
Leopold's funeral, in my opinion.
It's that he simply could not go.
But two months after Leopold died,
the starling died.
And from his garden in Vienna,
Mozart created a
grand and formal funeral.
So he buried the bird in the garden.
He invited friends to wear
formal mourning clothes and play music.
And he even wrote an eulogy for the bird.
And when people talk about this,
this contrast in Mozart not
attending his father's funeral
and then creating this
formal funeral for his bird,
most people, most biographers
don't mention it again.
But those that do pause
at two different theories.
One is that it was simply a joke.
(laughs) That it was over the top.
Mozart was always a prankster
and it would appeal to his sense of humor
to create a formal funeral for a bird.
And the other is that it was
a way of grieving his father.
That this is a little
bit of pop psychoanalysis
that people are doing that sort of
the vessel of the funeral
in any form offered a
channel for the grief
that he wasn't able to offer
in-person to his father.
And I honestly believe that
both of those things make sense.
Certainly a bird funeral would play
to Mozart's wonderful sense of the absurd.
And having a funeral could
be a container for his grief.
But there's a third option
that biographers never mention,
but that anyone living with a starling
could not help but realize,
and that is that it was just sincere.
Mozart loved his starling.
Here's a bird that, like him,
was a good mimic. (laughs)
Musical, mischievous,
intelligent and friendly.
And he lost this bird during a time when
he was in financial distress.
He lost a child.
He lost his father.
He was working very hard
at the time his dad died.
He was writing Don Giovanni.
And here's this musical,
cheerful presence with him
during all of this.
It was a sincere loss for him.
And he wrote an eulogy and
I'm gonna read it to you
because it's wonderful.
This is Marsha Davenport's
1932 translation.
A little fool lies here whom I held dear.
A starling in the prime of his brief time
whose doom it was to
drain death's bitter pain.
Thinking of this, my heart is riven apart.
A reader shed a tear and you also hear
he was not naughty, quite,
which is a line I love 'cause
that's what I think of Carmen.
She's not naughty, quite.
But gay and bright.
And under all his brag, a foolish wag.
This no one can gain say and I will lay
that he is now on high and
from the sky praises me
without pay in his friendly way.
Yet unaware that death
has choked his breath
and thoughtless of the one
whose rhyme is best well done.
I visited Mozart's grave.
No one knows exactly where he's buried but
because it's getting late,
I think I'm just gonna kind of move on.
This is his grave in Vienna.
It's at this beautiful tangled ancient
kind of haunted cemetery outside of town.
And there used to be a
really big memorial there
out of granite and sort of
the muse in contemplation.
And they took that
memorial in the late 1800s
and they moved it to the new
Vienna Municipal City Cemetery.
Other side of town.
And so all kinds of Mozart pilgrims go
and they think that big memorial
that it was sort of created to be this
garden of dead musicians,
Schumann is buried there,
Salieri, Beethoven,
and then they added this
memorial statue of Mozart.
You have to read the
fine print to find out
that Mozart's actually there.
Not there.
But in the actual graveyard where he is,
he was buried in a common grave,
which was the practice at the time.
And so they didn't put grave
markers in the exact place.
And so this is in the approximate place.
And when I was there,
you can't really tell that jungley tangle,
the sense of boldness and hauntedness
that enchants this cemetery.
But one of the things
that really struck me was
I kind of leaned down and
looked up at this cherub
and I expected him to be
contemplating some sort of,
the music of the spheres
and a sense of the spirit of Mozart.
But all I really got was this look of,
oh my gosh, I'm here forever
and he's not even buried here.
Just made me laugh.
There are now 200 million
starlings in North America.
And ecologically they are
somewhat disastrous in certain ways.
But individually they
have these bright minds,
these shining feathers,
this lovely unique consciousness
that is so instructive.
I think it makes us aware
when we walk in the world
that we are so deeply interconnected to
all of the kindred
of all of the more than human world.
And so I'm gonna just
finish with one little
sentence from the book.
And I'll let us keep
watching this murmuration.
We can talk about how
murmurations work in the Q&A
if you all want to.
So it is in reciprocity
to this idea of wonder and complexity
that we discover what draws
us, and along with it,
our originality, our creativity,
our soulness, our gladness, our art.
Mozart found inspiration in
the presence of a common bird.
For us too, the song of
the world so often rises
in places we had not thought to look.
So I'm gonna end with Mozart
and the starling there
for the moment.
I'll try to invite Carmen back.
I've got her favorite applesauce.
We'll try to draw her over.
But I'm going to just briefly
say, and I apologize for this,
but I have a book coming out next week
and I am basically under
contractual obligation
to mention it whenever I can.
My publicist wanted something
of me this afternoon
and I said, I can't deal with that.
I'm preparing for this lecture.
And she said, well, make
sure you mention your book.
And I'm slightly frightened of her.
So I'm mentioning my book.
Rooted: Life at the Crossroads
of Science, Nature, and
Spirit is available next week.
I hope that you'll stay in touch.
That's my personal,
oh my personal, I thought I
had my email address on there.
It's just lyandahaupt@gmail.com.
Please feel free to contact me
and follow along on any of the socials.
All right, I'd be
delighted to stay in touch.
So I'm gonna pop off
the stop share screen.
(mumbling)
- Great, thank you very much.
What a lovely talk.
- And say that,
I just want to say thank you.
I know this is a really platform.
I'm a really conversational speaker.
- Right now is the fun part,
'cause from here on in
it's gonna be real easy.
The vast majority of
your videos and sounds
were perfectly fine.
- Okay, good.
- Especially some of the
videos that were challenging before.
So yeah, I just want
to reflect that I think
anyone who has experienced
a bird as a pet or a domesticated bird
understands the kind of way that
it connects people to the
intelligence of birds,
the personality of birds in a unique way.
And so I think you're exactly right.
The avian intelligences,
plural, is a big part.
And I don't think anybody
who also had a pet bird
could doubt that Mozart
was sincere and not joking
in his celebration of the
life of this pet starling.
That was good.
So we have lots of comments in the,
and questions in the feed.
- Great.
- And I just remind, for those
of you who raise your hand,
if you can put your questions in the chat
then that will help us.
And I think I'll just start
with some of the questions
I've been reviewing it.
And Lyanda, if you want to field
or if you need any, if you have any,
or want to have a conversation
about any of these,
I'd be glad to help out.
So the first comes from Jane
McCall-Politi, who asked,
do starlings pass on
their linguistic abilities
to their offspring, to their children?
- Great, well, pass on
is an interesting phrase.
So it's unlikely that they
pass it on genetically,
but they do teach their offspring
some of their unique phrases.
So starlings have a lot
of complex vocalizations
that people hearing
them think that they're,
it's just wild craziness,
but when you study them
you find that there's an order to it.
But part of that order is
in every starling song,
it starts with a whistle
and then moves on to,
there's this little, some long whistles
and a crescendo and some rattles.
There's a section for personal repertoire.
So they will throw in
sounds that they favor,
that they've learned, that
they've mimicked themselves,
and it varies from
individual to individual.
But we do find that in family groups,
males and female partners, mates,
will start picking up and
mimicking back to one another
each individual's own mimic sounds.
And then the young will
also pick up on the
unique individual
repertoires of the parents.
That said, the young will go on
and create their own repertoire
and choose their own
mimic sounds to add in.
So there's a lot of sharing and learning
but it doesn't seem to
be genetically passed on.
- Yeah, yeah, great.
And so a question from Susan Honi is,
how do starlings compare
to the lyrebirds as mimics?
- Oh, nothing compares to
the lyrebirds as mimics.
We've all seen the David
Attenborough footage
of the lyrebird doing
the rewind of the camera.
And I personally feel that starlings,
although they are so gifted
and they can pick up so much
and they can learn songs
and it's incredibly impressive,
there's always a whistly birdiness to it.
And the things that
Carmen and other starlings
mimic that sound,
when I say it's pitch perfect
and we can't tell them apart,
that's something like
the beep of a microwave.
So that is a very kind
of birdish sound anyway.
But otherwise there's a
whistly birdiness to it,
that in the lyrebird, somehow
they're on another plane.
So humans have larynxes,
birds have syrinxes.
And so there's a lot of
variation in the vocal cords,
in the vocal apparatus,
that allow different species
to have different capacities.
And the lyrebird is
like the great. (laughs)
Feel free to--
- Really too, I mean,
the closest relatives to the starlings,
which are about 120 species total,
are the new world mockingbirds
and their relatives.
So the capacity for mimicry evolutionarily
goes quite far back in this history.
But not all starlings do it.
And the other way to
think about it is that
starlings have more of
their own stuff to say.
So mimicry is a smaller
part of their repertoire
'cause they have starling stuff to do.
And that's less true of lyrebird,
who is mostly composing its repertoire
from other species' songs.
- Yeah, that's really interesting.
Yeah, starlings have a really
high plasticity of behavior
so they have a lot going on, yeah.
- So a question from Bruce MacIntyre.
Do birds have perfect pitch?
What do you think?
- I don't know, I don't know.
I mean, starlings,
do you know the answer to that?
- Well, I would say,
I don't think they have names for pitches
so they're not gonna say,
oh, that's a C sharp.
But obviously in order to
learn from conspecifics,
they do have to match on on frequency.
And what's also interesting
of course is that
they have the individual
motivation to do, perhaps innovate.
So they don't do it slavishly,
but they clearly have
that capacity, I think.
- Right, and when you
hear young birds learning,
especially males in the fall,
sometimes they'll already
start learning their song,
their adult song.
And they're very imperfect.
So we can hear them
working to get it right.
And I hear that with Carmen
when she is learning to mimic.
Her current project is the Bewick's wren
who's singing outside in the
camellia outside of her window.
And she practices.
She gets it wrong and wrong
and then she eventually gets it right.
- That's social learning.
One of my advisors, Bob Payne,
published a paper that a local house finch
had learned from a canary that
one of the neighbors put out on her porch
so that the bird could sing outside.
So it goes even from
domestication into the wild,
not just the other way.
- So fun.
- A question from Susan.
Is Carmen a female and does
she lay unfertilized eggs?
- Okay, Carmen is a female.
And it's really hard to tell,
unless you've done a lot
of starling watching,
there's not a lot of
dimorphism between the feathers
of the males and females.
But in the breeding season especially,
the males have these sort of
punky feathers on their wings
and their neck feathers
are extra plumey and,
uh-oh, there's a cat on the loose.
I finally remembered
to put the kitten away.
This cat is very fat though.
Give me one second.
I'm just gonna lock this fat cat up.
Come here, Delilah.
(laughing)
- That is just, that has
been such a fascinating talk.
Oh my God, so many questions, yeah.
So Rick, do--
- We don't want any tragedies here.
- No.
- Lyanda, Rick, I cannot
resist chiming in here.
So does Carmen have her personal song?
- Yeah, so, okay.
So what Carmen does is,
and this is really interesting because
a lot of passerine birds have
vocalizations that are innate.
If you get them when they're
young like I did Carmen
and she wasn't really
exposed to Carmen's songs,
and yet she sings the full range of
the typical female song.
So it starts with a whistle
and then her own repertoire of sounds.
And then
another kind of rattly sound
and this crescendo whistle at the end.
And males add in this rattling song thing.
So it goes, there's just a formula
for starling songs and she sings it.
But she definitely has her
own repertoire of mimic sounds
and she will integrate that
into the typical starling pattern.
It's fascinating.
I hope that, is that what your question?
- Yeah, that was my question.
And I guess it would be great, Rick.
And does the signature
song change with age?
- Well, as Lyanda pointed out,
most of the birds that learn their songs
learn or basically hit the target
within the end of the first year,
the first spring or the second year.
And then stay,
the single song or the
entire repertoire unchanged.
There are, however, some birds
that are much more open-ended
and mimicry is a great
way to get open-ended.
That's probably why mimicry evolved at all
because there was either
social choice or made choice
for a very open or extreme repertoire.
And if you keep learning other songs,
your repertoire keeps growing.
It's more innovative and novel.
But another bird that learns their song
continuously throughout life is a canary,
which is the wild species that
the domestic canary came from.
So canaries learn their song renewed.
Every spring, they have, the wild ones,
have a new rush of song
innovation and learning.
Made a note back in the '90s.
I found out that that
was actually associated
with the origin of new
neurons in the brain
and on control areas,
which was part of the discovery
that bird brains can grow new neurons,
which prior to that was not understood.
But that fundamental biological fact
which is now underlies
treatment for stroke
and neurodegenerative disorders in humans
was discovered in bird song
with exactly this question in mind.
- And Lyanda, just a quick
final comment slash question.
It might be crazy.
But Lyanda, do you hear
emotion when she improvises?
- Oh.
- I know this is probably
not a fair question.
And it's deeply possible that you--
- I don't know about emotion.
I mean, I think that she is definitely,
she gets more excited when she hears
certain music compared to other music.
And I personally, I have
to say, I'm not against,
in science, there's this whole,
oh my gosh, we don't
want to anthropomorphize.
And I actually think along 160 years ago,
Darwin himself said that he didn't,
in positing natural selection
as a mechanism for evolution,
he didn't see any difference
in positing condition of morphological
validity and consciousness both.
He didn't think it made any sense
that there was a
morphological continuation
but consciousness somehow
stopped with humans.
And he readily called animals
peaceable, calm, happy, whatever.
So, and I think that we've
really, really restricted
the ways that we understand
different intelligences
by not allowing ourselves
to just acknowledge that
sometimes we recognize
when an animal is in pain
or is in distress or agitated.
At the same time, we don't
want to over-attribute.
So when you say emotions,
I paused for a minute,
but I do think that there
are times when she's engaged,
when she's satisfied,
when she's not agitated.
And a lot of that has to do
with what's going on aurally.
- Lyanda, if I may, we
have a great question
from Professor Brown,
who's President of the
Mozart Society of America.
He says, the L at the end of starl,
as it was called in that initial note
on the purchase and the ledger
makes it a diminutive in the German.
Do you imagine that it was a baby,
a chick starling, when
Mozart purchased Star?
- I mean, I can look into it further,
but as I understand it, that was a,
that was one of the German
common names for starling.
(speaking in foreign language)
And it meant little star because,
and it's one of the reasons
that we call starlings
starlings in their common name.
And they fly, they have pointed wings,
pointed tails, pointed noses,
and they look like little
stars when they're in flight.
And that's one theory of where
the common name came from.
And so it might've just been little star
rather than baby starling.
And Mozart was a decent naturalist.
He knew something about
or he was interested in the natural world,
and he certainly knew the common
species name for the bird.
And so later biographers reading
that note would think that,
thought that he named the
bird Star based on that note.
But he was really just labeling it
according to the common name.
So to answer the question though,
it's unlikely that it was a baby
because one of the
things that caused Mozart
or urged Mozart to purchase
this particular bird
was that it was singing the
motif from the concerto.
And birds, even gifted
mimics like starlings,
are not able to mimic
that something complex
until they're several years old.
And I, or rather, several months old.
And for many reasons,
given the time of year,
it was May.
And so starlings are young in May,
are born in May even in
now Austria where Mozart was.
And so it could not have been a baby.
It would have had to be
about a year old at that time
to be singing that level of complexity.
So my conjecture is that
it's a year old bird.
And he died three years later.
So at about four years of age.
Great question.
- Indeed.
In August 1784, Emperor
Joseph the II decreed
new burial regulations in
Vienna for sanitation reasons,
which later led to Mozart's
quote unquote anonymous
shroud burial in 1791.
By burying his dear Star,
the composer was probably breaking a law.
And that's thanks to Bruce
MacIntyre, great contribution.
- Yeah.
It's true, people feel that Mozart was,
there's this myth that Mozart
was buried in a pauper's grave
and no one attended his funeral.
And it's seen as this
view that he was sort of
spat upon by the city to
which he gave so much.
But as the commenter says, it's just,
it was new regulations by Joseph the II
and for sanitation and for frugality.
There was so much excess in the funeral
processions before that.
And these were changes
that Mozart agreed with.
So yeah, he was buried in a grave
with about 10 other people.
The shroud, through some lye on top.
And then in 10 years' time,
they would reuse that
plot for other people.
- We had a participant ask
about the participatory mode,
I think you were mentioning.
Do you remember that part of your talk?
And could you go over that again, please?
- Okay, so what I was
really saying is that
what I initially thought in
terms of Carmen's mimicry
was participation in the household.
That she was just picking
up environmental sounds.
And I'm gonna be,
I'm gonna tell you,
this is gonna reflect poorly upon me
but the first environmental
sound that she learned,
she could say, hi and
hi, honey and come here.
But I heard her making the
sound that went (creaking).
And I thought, what is that sound?
And I finally figured out one day
that it's the vacuum on the wine cork.
You know how you have those
that vacuums out the extra air?
So her first environmental sound was
associated with me hitting
the bottle. (laughs)
Not really hitting the bottle,
just sipping the Chardonnay.
But anyway, I kind of thought
that, for a long time,
that she was just
learning household sounds.
But what turned out to be
the actual case was that
although she was learning
to mimic household sounds,
she wasn't just doing them along with us.
She was doing them in anticipation
of the sound that she knew
was going to happen next.
And that is the fascination of the,
just the complexity of
the mindscape of this bird
that she introduced to me.
I mean, when I brought
Carmen into the home
as part of research
for creating this book,
I kind of thought I knew
what was gonna happen.
She was gonna mimic a lot and
that was gonna be interesting.
She might learn the Mozart
motif and that would be great.
But instead she just
really upended my sense
of the possibilities of the
infinity of intelligences
that surround us in
the beyond human world.
So that idea of, and
this is little understood
in the literature, little
researched in the literature,
because it's something
that you can't figure out
just hanging out with a bird in a lab.
But it just takes months of sort of
living day in and day out
to finally figure out the pattern that
she's not just singing along
or not just singing your favorite songs.
She's listening to you
open the microwave door
and then before the beeps
come, she's making the beeps.
She's anticipating
what's gonna happen next.
She's just there waiting to say, I'm here.
I know what's gonna happen and here it is.
It's wonderful.
- One of the last questions.
Does Carmen communicate
intelligently with other species?
So we know you have cats, for instance.
Does she talk with the cat,
to the cat, at the cat?
- Well, she mimics the cat.
So when she sees the cat, she does meow
'cause she knows the cat's gonna meow.
And as I said, she has this anticipatory
relationship with life.
But.
One of the reasons that she's
not releasable to the wild,
in addition to not knowing
how to fend for herself
and not knowing the complicated
starling social networks,
is that she thinks cats are her friends.
So I don't let the cats out
when Carmen is flying around
just because sometimes you can see
the instinct coming over
them and they're just,
the arm is, they know they're
not supposed to kill stuff
that lives in the house.
But sometimes the instinct is just,
one of these days, it would arise.
So the thing that does happen though,
is when one of the cats goes
to the aviary and sits on it's,
the aviary goes from the ceiling
all the way to the floor,
and the cat will go up to the wire,
put their noses right up to the wire,
and Carmen will come and put her bill
right next to their nose.
Right next to it.
And they'll maybe swat at her,
and she just jumps back about two inches.
And then, so they socialize together.
I mean, I think the cats
just want to kill her,
but Carmen thinks, oh,
it's like it's visiting me.
Whenever anyone goes to Carmen's aviary,
she just comes right up to see them
and looks right into their
eyes and tilts their head.
And she does that with the cats as well.
- And she might perceive that she's safe
thanks to the aviary enclosure too.
- Oh, she does, but I don't
know what would happen if she,
yeah, I don't trust her to know better.
(laughing)
- Thank you.
Let's see, other questions.
Did I miss any?
We had people asking,
can you purchase an adult
starling as Mozart did?
Nope.
And someone else already
said it would be illegal.
Is that because they're non-native?
- So it's actually interesting.
I mean, I do not recommend
having a starling as a pet.
They're very, very high
maintenance, takes a lot of work.
But it is also illegal.
In some states you are
able to get a license
to have one as a pet.
When I talked to our own
Washington State Fish and Wildlife person
and asked why we are
allowed to, with impunity,
kill adult starlings
without telling anyone,
it's fine, it's legal,
it's even encouraged,
why can we not just have one in the house?
And he said that they
are worried about people
propagating them as pets.
And it's kind of a silly worry
because there are so many starlings
and we kill lots of starlings.
We kill millions of starlings a year
for agricultural protection.
But it doesn't make a dent
in the starling population.
And so someone would have to release
a heck of a lot of starlings
in order for it to make any difference.
And it's hard to imagine what
the motive for doing that would be.
So I'm not saying that
I think it's a good idea
for people to have pet starlings,
but I don't think it makes
sense for us to be able to
kill them or whatever but
not keep them as pets.
But there is no legal
starling trade out there.
You'll have to, you're on your own,
if you want to get a starling.
- I thought it was especially
interesting in your book
how you delved into the rather brutal ways
in which it's open season on starlings
and the various, I remember,
some of the harrowing
stories you told of people
doing their bit, I suppose,
to protect native species by
killing off the starlings.
And yet one of the things I
really gathered from your talk
and your book was how doing so,
and such a focus on eradicating them,
inures us to their own special nature.
And this greater intelligence
that we can gather
and immerse ourselves in
of these animals that are
otherwise unwelcome here.
They did come here at our own hand.
It was the one who brought them over,
releasing them in the part
of the Shakespearian story.
And it taught me to look, for instance,
at the house sparrows outside nesting.
They have a beauty and a
rhythm of their own life
and that has value too.
So thank you for that.
- Right, I mean, one of the
things is it's not either or.
One of the things that's
so beautiful about
the complexity of human intelligence
is that we can hold both of
these things at one time.
We can dislike starlings ecologically,
we can understand that their
presence is an ecological harm,
and yet we can be inspired or
by the interconnection that
their consciousness invites
and just by their, even
just by their beauty.
So it's not one or the other.
We can do all of these things at once.
And that's one of the things I tried to do
with this research was
invite that kind of nuance.
- Great.
I guess, Rick, do you have any closing
questions of your own?
- No, no, I enjoyed this thoroughly
and I'm fascinated to see this
new angle on understanding
bird intelligence and
also the history of others
who appreciate it as well.
So thanks very much.
- Yeah, so at this point,
I want to say a big thank
you to Lyanda and to Rick
for this wonderful, wonderful event.
And we are wishing you the
best for your new book.
And can't wait to read that too.
And continue to have fun with Carmen.
It was so nice and generous
of you to share her
sort of flying around
and I'm glad she decided to
participate in today's session.
- Me too. (laughs)
I want to thank everyone.
Thank you for bearing with
the technological rockiness
and also just the sort of awkwardness
of the talking head way that this platform
requires us to communicate.
But the Q&A is always the most fun
and I'm just delighted
to be part of the series.
Again, I want to thank
everyone so much for having me
and for listening.
And Professor Rick, thank you.
You're a delight.
I'm a fan of your work
and it was so fun to be here with you.
- Yeah, so thank you everyone
for attending and talked.
Thank you so much, Ty Kamp
for helping making it
all go very smoothly.
So bye, everyone.